la tristesse était une sorte de personnage rond et
détrempé j'ai fait quelque chose de bien à
propos de cette posture vous savez qui semble un
peu rocheuse il y a beaucoup d'
exploration pour la tristesse et ce que cela
pourrait être
certaines des conceptions précédentes sont peut-être un
peu trop mélancoliques j'appelle  c'est un
peu comme une méthode de conception de personnages d'une
certaine manière, vous devez en quelque sorte ressentir de la
tristesse Je mettrais les écouteurs
et essayerais de la musique triste J'essaierais juste d'
entrer dans cet état même si nos
personnages sont des émotions spécifiques dont nous avons
réalisé qu'ils vont avoir besoin  pour agir sur une
gamme complète d'émotions et pas seulement
s'en tenir à leur seule émotion particulière,
donc la tristesse devrait également agir
heureuse et à quoi cela ressemblerait-il
à quoi ressemblerait un triste heureux alors
réalisez que cela allait être beaucoup de
mélange